all right I think it's rolling is okay
yeah we're on our life all right
hey out there you guys I love you so far
yeah yeah we decided what we're gonna do
today because like I said you know
normally it's Tuesday and normally are
normally we would put up the you know
regular episode today but obviously we
already put that up early because it was
like the dream and everything so I
thought well let's just do another
livestream today hi Tammy um you know
just to have something to put up and
also I had had like a couple of messages
about various true crime cases that we
had covered in the past you know hi
Thomas and also so I thought that we
could do like a sidetrack show about
that and also got a lot of shout outs
that I want to do and like I said I
don't like to leave it until like you
know the main episode to like shout
people out just in case they don't see
it hey Beth hey Joanie so it's like so
okay this is this microphone on yeah
yeah yeah I know I keep having to
because it keeps default airy or micro
there right that microphone which sounds
like a tin can
but yeah so I had to check yeah so um I
guess we'll start out by doing like some
shout outs because this week we got
three new patrons damn I didn't know
about that yeah so Thomas Melissa G and
Sydney okay so hey thank you very very
much also I wanted to give another like
humongous shout out to everyone that
gave us donations during our 200th
episode livestream yeah we did a good
night which was yeah that was I was
really surprised I was like not well I
mean we were I'm doing that we were just
doing that because a lot of people I
know please do a live stream and I said
oh that'll be neat like special to do
for you know for our 200th episode and
that was like a $400 night it was I was
like Brandon yeah they take 30% of it
but still that was money we wouldn't
have made well yeah yes you guys like I
said I wasn't really I didn't really do
like a nice surprise I was a big bonus
though and I'd also like to thank Dan
who's also one of our patrons and Sophie
because donation today as did Dan he
sent us one like after they
after the last train for the 200th
episode also I noticed today that we had
finally finally broken 9000
subscriptions
yeah only 1000 more to get well a little
less than I think it was nine thousand
and twelve like last time I looked
hi Christine hi Melissa hi Austin
they're all still Sandra yes good here
we are like I said I put up this morning
I think I put it up at like 9 o'clock
okay our time this morning that we going
on like I David hi Melanie so yeah so
that's pretty cool pointing out new so
because sometimes I don't see like all
the new store especially if it's just
kind of buried under the thing and it's
like a true-crime can I have more
information we can deal with actually
yeah it's just kind of coming in and I'm
just kind of like trying to window
things out and like trying to get other
stuff down as well but um there were two
there were updates on two cases that we
had done shows about in the past so I
was informed about both of those so I
just kind of want to talk about that a
little bit so obviously big news in the
original Nightstalker Joseph James
D'Angelo case they have mentioned that
on June 29th he is probably going to
plead guilty to all charges oh thank you
Matt thank you very much um you know
thanks man in in lieu of the death
penalty now they are saying that that
the thing about it is that even though
this plea deal has kind of apparently
from what I've read has been on the
table since the beginning like ever
since they caught him because he's
elderly and a lot of the witnesses are
also elderly and also because his crimes
had been committed in several different
jurisdictions and it was going to be
they couldn't decide where they were
gonna try them and all this other stuff
so apparently they decided the best
thing to do especially with you know the
you know cope at 19 and like the lock
downs and it was going to be a pain in
the ass like to get people to you know
give deposition to give witness
testimony and so like I said some other
witnesses had died or were you know in
bad health or whatever so I'm thinking
that this is probably the best situation
for all involved because honestly the
thing about it is that the dude is old
and had he gotten the death penalty you
know he wouldn't both all the appeals
and stuff he never would have gotten it
anyway
um so I feel like him pleading guilty
and just going to prison for the rest of
his life hopefully suffering prison is
probably the best outcome especially
because he walked around free for so
long he got away with it basically he
did I mean I mean that's what's shitty
it doesn't matter what his plea is
really because he can plead not guilty
he would still spend the rest of his
life in prison fighting it yeah because
that's a 20-year battle yeah so you
might as well just say [ __ ] it I don't
want it I don't want all these court
dates yeah that's just my plead guilty
to it I mean like I said it seems like
the best situation for all involved
because it I don't know like I don't
really think anyone was really like
super dead set on him getting the death
penalty because like you said I knew you
know people he wasn't gonna get it
anyway or take it too long and it cuz it
would have taken two I mean death
penalty and what they did is they
probably cut him a real sweet deal
they're like look you'd save us a lot of
money if you'd go ahead and just plea to
this yeah and what we'll do is we'll get
you out if I can county jail and we'll
send you to a real sweet [ __ ] place
in the penitentiary system they probably
promised him to go to a much better
place that had more you know I mean
medical facilities and better you would
have call it canteen yeah and you know
okay okay Tyrion will give you a job or
some [ __ ] like that yeah I mean like I
said he still got away with it it's like
there's no way we can go back in time
and like catch him you know would have a
nice way to caught him before he was
identified though before he died and now
yeah now it's you know he knows that's
on his name he didn't totally get away
with it but yeah that's true all those I
I heard like somebody pointed out that
um I'm not sure how it works in like all
different states but I know that if you
die like while you'd like before you get
convicted of anything like anything like
that it's like you're still considered
innocent I guess like you're not really
considered like those cases are still
considered unsolved which I guess would
just be a legality because they're
pretty sure that that's there did it but
you know so that might be [ __ ] up for
that but honestly I I haven't heard
anybody like in the victims families or
anything like that complaining about
this particularly because I'm sure none
of them really want to go [ __ ] through
all the [ __ ] of like having to look at
his stupid face like in the courtroom
every day because I certainly would not
so I guess that's kind of the best thing
that
can be hoped for so we'll see if he's
actually gonna do it he hasn't actually
done it yet apparently it's supposed to
be like on the 29th of June that he's
gonna come out and say that he's gonna
plead guilty so he doesn't get the death
penalty now another case that has just
had a humungous you know update was and
if you remember back in March when we
did our I think it was our third like
creepy disappearances show and we talked
about the disappearance of Joshua JJ
valo who was 7 years old and his I
believe it was his half-sister his
stepsister Ty Lee Ryan who was 17 and
they went missing in I believe September
2019 and it was like some sketchy [ __ ]
like with the parents and the stepdad
and all this other stuff these two
children's bodies have been found they
were found on June 10th I believe June
9th or Jim 10th so they found them
buried in the backyard of Joshua fallows
mom's like husband the new husband Chad
day bail they found him in his backyard
now at the moment they are only he has
been arrested but at the moment they're
only charging him with like hiding
evidence or something like that because
I don't know if there's any if there's
enough evidence to convict him now they
are looking into him obviously like as a
suspect because if you remember we
talked about this like I said back in
March on our creepy disappearances show
but you know this is before they had
found them when the kids were still
missing and most people had assumed that
the parents definitely had something to
do with it because these two that this
is like a [ __ ] up case and I was like
reading again like I was refreshing my
memory like on the Wikipedia page and
it's like what's this [ __ ] crazy [ __ ]
because the thing about it is like the
way the kids went missing
um you know JJ who was 7 years old like
I said he was seen September 23rd at his
elementary school and then he
disappeared after that and then Ty Lee
Ryan who was 17 she was seen September
8th but they didn't really realize
because like I said the parents don't
report her missing so nobody realized
that she was missing until after like JJ
had gone missing also in other relatives
like got suspicious about it were
like hey where the [ __ ] are those two
kids and then all this other should
happen because the bomb lorry valo she
initially told police that JJ was
staying with a friend of the family so
the police called the friend of the
family whose name was Melanie Gibbs and
you know Melanie Gibbs was like no he's
not here I haven't seen him for a really
long time and knocked the kids off I'm
kind of I mean you know what I mean
I wonder why it's just they were bad
well yeah it was like seemed like
terrible people so no I meant the kids
the kids were bad so they knocked him
off it was a joke oh I was like sitting
there going well obviously there's kind
of story behind it we were in the Army
one day at one time and [ __ ] we were
watching the news on TV is back in the
90s and some mom had killed one of her
kids and chased the other ones out the
back door and then killed that one with
a knife these are like six to seven year
old kids I think and she had just given
birth to another one I think she drowned
it or some [ __ ] like that
damn it must've been some kind of
postpartum depression you know well
somebody in the dayroom goes the helps
you do that for and it's some another
guy said because they were bad I mean if
you've never had I don't have any kids
but it's like I grew up around kids cuz
I've also Shih Tzu [ __ ] just went down a
couple days ago saw on television I
don't know all the details yet it found
some kind of like half-dressed starving
kid walking around with a damn chain on
his neck or something and it led back to
a house run by two old people and they
had some kids in there chained up and
they were starving them to death and one
of them was dead and buried out in a
damn backyard my god it's like the
people under the stairs yeah and they
don't they had legal custody of the kids
I don't know maybe if they were foster
kids or they'd adopted him or maybe they
got custody through some family somehow
I don't know it I didn't really I heard
his [ __ ] and I was like I don't wanna
hear any more of that I'm sorry
so that might be a good show once we
know more about it yes do you guys know
what case I'm talking about it happened
maybe like a week ago
I might
- because one of the shows not the next
one we're doing but I definitely like
before the end of the month or early
next month I want to do one because I
know a lot of people have asked us to do
when I'm like sex slave kidnapping is
like aerial capture and stuff like that
so I definitely want to do one of those
like in the next couple weeks if that's
kind of similar then maybe we can add it
to that show as well but yeah so not
only are these did the kids missing and
it will now they know that they're dead
they found them like buried in the yard
but listen to this [ __ ] so it's like
like I said they were suspicious of
Laurie valo and Chad de Belle from the
beginning because they lied about where
the kids were and we're like really
cagey about oh yeah they're here they're
there we don't know where they're you
know what I mean don't look at us so you
know they've kind of been under
suspicion and I believe that um I
believe that Laurie Vala was arrested
back in November for abandonment
basically for abandoning the children
because like I said then they didn't
know that the kids were dead but the
weird thing about this was so July of
2019 Laurie Val OHS estranged husband or
ex-husband or something like that he was
killed by Laurie's brother like Laurie's
brother shot and killed him but he got
away with it because he said it was
self-defense which the police were like
okay fine then the brother died of a
blood clot in December of last year then
there was a guy named Brandon Boudreau
who was the estranged husband of Laurie
bellows nice he was shot at in the
driveway of his house that was in
Arizona and then he hired a private
investigator and the private
investigator was one of the first ones
to notice that the kids were missing
another thing too was that also in
October of 2019
Chad de belles wife Tammy she was shot
at in her driveway as well although she
thinks it was a paintball gun she wasn't
really sure but then a few weeks later
she died in her sleep from natural
causes which I kind of doubt now they
didn't poison they didn't do yeah they
didn't do an autopsy or anything like
that so if she had been poisoned then
and then Chad de Belle ended up marrying
Laurie valo like two weeks after Tatum
II died yeah so it's like this seems a
little suspend a little suspicious
suspicious there I mean come on they're
asking for pokey pokies in the cat tree
in the very top of course she's taking a
nap leaping around she's like she's just
right outside that door yeah she's up in
her she's up in her little top apartment
cuz you know our cat tree if you've seen
on the video it has like three little
apartments and then it has like three
little bowls yeah like that you can sit
in a little like she likes and she bowls
and the apartments yeah she she kind of
switches between the apartment and the
bowl yeah you know during the day she's
kind of like notables kind of nice and
she could look out the window with the
birds and then she gets up and gets open
cuddles up in the thing but yeah so yeah
so Laurie valo she was arrested in
February of this year and that was
desertion non-support then she got
extradited to Idaho and then she
originally had five million dollar bail
but I guess that they you know lowered
it down to 1 million now after that like
I guess they I don't know why it took
him so long to like search chad de
belles house but they only just have
search warrant on june 9th which is like
a few days ago and then they dug up his
backyard and found the two bodies and
then they like you know of these two
[ __ ] kids so like I said they arrest
him but not for murder just for a
concealment of evidence and he's
pleading not guilty maybe the woman
killed him
it could be um but I feel like well he
probably had to know about it I'm sure
because and I'm pretty sure I mean you
can't really say allegedly allegedly but
you know it seems very very suspicious
that several of several people like
relatives and like hanger like ex
husbands and wives and things like that
around these two turned up dead you know
what I mean
that just seems really suspicious
they're just like killing everybody and
it just seems like they're not being
particularly secretive about it it's
still getting away with it so I don't
know so de Bell is in jail even though
you know if that's all he gets convicted
of concealment of evidence it's like
five years of jail and a thousand dollar
fine that's like it but they are
investigating him for other [ __ ] so I
guess they're just keeping him in there
for that like until they can get some
more dirt on him apparently and I didn't
know I don't know if I mentioned this on
the
original show that we did about the
missing kids but apparently both lorry
valo and Chad de Bell are in one of
those weird religious cults that think
that at the end of the world has come in
like the Apothic apocalypse or whatever
it's starting to make sense now like yes
so I killed him because if she didn't
kill him she would have gone to the
police he was protecting her cuz she
killed him yeah maybe she killed him
because they were possessed by the devil
oh man that's a [ __ ] that's [ __ ] like
that [ __ ] that somebody like that well
yeah there was something like that had
gone on it's some kind of weird compound
out you guys might remember where that
was there was some kind of Muslim I
don't know if they were Middle Eastern
Muslims or if they were American Muslims
but there were a black family and they
around a desert and they had a damn ring
a damn looked like truck cars you know
empty truck trucks and [ __ ] around this
little homemade compound and they were
running out of food and they took one of
the kids the little boy tortured him and
crucified him to make him experience the
sufferings of Christ and this would
bring on the MIDI or something the the
the Muslim when he call it kind of like
a pop apocalyptic figure right and
during the apocalypse but evidently they
had damn crucified that kid and for some
reason they let him go that's what last
I heard with charge of religious freedom
I guess I don't know I don't know how
these people that's not our religious
freedom or they let him go though from
what I remember I mean I haven't looked
in maybe they recharge them I don't know
but maybe somebody in the comment
sections might know we hey that might be
a good show too because that's been a
couple years well weren't there like
some sit like some kind of weird cult
like some offshoot cults or offshoot
sects of the Mormons that were thought
to have like killed a bunch of people
like buried the kids out in the desert
and [ __ ] like that
well yeah that was those damn brides
yeah Broadway brides that's right yeah
we say they tried to run away from the
compound
yeah certain some of those Mormon cults
basically just them sex cults really you
know I mean it's a all the old guys
trading young women with each other
through all these big network of brides
I don't know Holly with a nice little
veneer of religion yeah
and they throw the boys away and they'll
end up homeless and [ __ ] and then the
girls try to run away and they have cops
real policemen but they're in that
religion yeah and they'll go out and
catch those girls and give them back
over to the elder and sometimes the
church elders kill and bury them out
there past the sent death sentence on
them but that's like out another desert
Mormon territory yeah and you know
they're they're what they call this
breakaway sex yeah you know but my
understanding you know Mormon writings
they're actually following what what
what the writings say so they're but
they're just kind of using it to their
own purpose the main part of the church
though doesn't do that anymore
yeah but in a way you don't I mean they
they could say well it's reformed but la
people didn't want to accept the
reformed yeah I knew Mormons you know
went to school with them as far as I
knew they all had one wife I don't know
if you know I mean maybe there were
other ones that they had stashed out
back in Salt Lake City but I think there
was mostly mostly one wife I think yeah
it looked like it well the thing about
it is they could I mean you can only
legally marry one anyway
if you know how there's other ones right
that's not to stop you from like having
a whole harem but you can do that
anywhere what they were doing part of
the scam is that you're married to one
wife right but then all the other sister
wives I think is with the call yeah
they're all considered single mothers
and they put them all on welfare
they call it bleeding the beast so yeah
so that guy can make a [ __ ] ton of money
off all these wives you know and they're
all on welfare yeah so you know most
most religions have an element to scam
you know but don't be all high and
mighty because if you believe in
politics politics is a [ __ ] element of
scam and that - mango badger says on the
plus side we got the Osmonds yeah
is that yes I guess what was fun
funny about Mormons is that every Mormon
I knew went to school with her they were
all good-looking well they were all real
good-looking okay because they it had a
long history of selective breeding in
fact you know Margaret Sanger and all
those early geneticist people everything
used him as a testbed even the kind of
like the German National Socialist you'd
know mezda Nazis the Nazis looked at a
lot of their birth records and saw that
they had weeded out a bunch of diseases
which helps support the racial hygiene
theory that you can breed healthier
people by you know by taking by not
allowing sick people to have children
you know you got rid of the [ __ ]
hemophiliacs and diabetes and stuff like
that which the Germans knew that anyway
they just wanted to prove it because the
Germans had been animal breeders for
[ __ ] centuries some of the best dogs
and horses you could buy what German
breeds you know so they were just gonna
breed themselves yeah why not that's
where all that Superman concept you know
Nazis Superman stuff
well he's self reading The Joy Division
yeah yeah well that's kind of like that
was that was like a different breeding
program but yeah that was that was women
young women giving up their reproductive
services to high-ranking genetically
superior SS men and they were gonna
raise children in the name of the state
this ultimate [ __ ] ultimate [ __ ]
totalitarian socialist concept raising
children for the state like a human
incubator yeah well the way they looked
at though you know you had young guys
giving their lives in the war or the
[ __ ] Eastern Front so the women were
giving up their uterus is to make
replacement Germans for the dead in
anywhere you raised him in orphanages
replacement German replacement German
that's very funny yeah I well I really
like this
the Ty Lee Ryan and Joshua Valu case I
really want to look more
into because a lot of the news coverage
like just kind of has some [ __ ] about
the religion thing but has it gone like
super in-depth on it so I would actually
like to look into that because I do I
feel like that's probably a factor and
like I said it seems very odd that all
of these other murders have happened
around these lunatics and I mean that
can't be a coincidence right that like
all of these wives and husbands and
nieces and nephews and stuff for like
turning up dead maybe they're - I don't
know why does maybe they're just trying
to [ __ ] I don't know what it is
they're doing
yeah because somebody like yeah there's
sin in the comments JJ was dark would
they be by that like that they were not
evil yeah yes or the dev like the kids
were evil or some yeah so that's
probably like what the justification
ones yeah I figured usually usually it's
religious type murders are about that
well they didn't pass the grade yeah and
that happens a lot too with um you know
these these cults that still do like
exorcisms and stuff like that and a
bunch of kids have died that way like
with the parents like because they'll
like try to smother him or like you know
they died or and the exorcisms they
don't feed them we're getting water or
anything like that we have to understand
you know fantasy from people are kind of
susceptible to these kind of systems
anyway it's just bad that these same
fantasy prom people have carry innocent
victims along with oh well yeah it'd be
one thing if they just lives just them
themselves one would complain right but
it's just a kid that don't have any
choice about who their grandparents were
right they actually had weird cults
out in California out in the West they
were they existed for a long time where
it was basically I think was called
children of God wouldn't it yeah we
talked about them in our culture like
the one thought about them I think more
it was it looks like Christianity it
used kind of like a Christian veneer but
what it was is it was the idea was is
that you should have a bunch of children
they're like quiver full children yeah
and then you loan your children out to
other families so they can all have sex
with them it was a huge network of child
molesters that have like a Christian
veneer on it and they would
me chocolates and [ __ ] make candles I
think you don't send him out and sell
all this stuff make pies and they lived
in campers and crap the event they
eventually bought like a bunch of
apartments and they were living in it
you know religiously sanctified
pedophiles and evidently the government
knew all about it and just said well
that with their interpretation of the
[ __ ] law I guess they thought it was
this is mostly 70s I think yeah I was
like I don't think he can get away
congroo it now well because like I said
you know religious freedom only goes so
far if you're committing actual crime
yes then it's not really well one of
those kids grew up and he was [ __ ]
trying to complain about it and get help
nobody would help him so he passed
judgment on the whole cult got an
assault rifle went down there and kill a
whole bunch of them yeah
then shot himself yeah Oh Thomas
Carlisle asked what religion was
Heaven's Gate yeah what was that even
basic gate was I was like a UFO is just
a photo I mean I don't even know like
where I don't know enough about there I
know about it we never did a show about
them to know he needs you though we
should we probably that guy's name what
was that clowns name oh man I can see
his face yeah he look like a human et
and what she wanted to look like a human
et well yeah because then you could
actually say that yeah well he was as
she was a pedophile he went to prison
for it got in trouble and then decided
to get all in UFOs after that and cut
his junk off that that's what kept him
out of trouble
so he wanted to become a sexual and an
extraterrestrial you know I'd rather
bits I'd rather be an extra testicle
testicle an extraterrestrial cut off
really need an extra testicle and more
testosterone is it I guess then you
[ __ ] live being able to like find
underwear that fit
no he'd fit in there there'd always be
like one like up in your taint and stuff
no I had a second hanging inside anyway
like one of those mutants cray but he
did is he built a he built a whole
empire these nerdy
web designers and hey no they were just
nerdy web designers did you see him yeah
nerdy UFO a likes an admin traffic
designer don't hate y'all kind of wore a
little jogging suit and sneakers and
they had a little et uniform they were
making the bad and they lived on a
compound and just did IT work online
which is way ahead of its time back in
the 90s oh yeah some futuristic [ __ ]
well the thought the hell Bob convict
the hell Bob comet was coming and their
interpretation of the hell Bob comet is
that behind it the alien mothership
would be there to collect their souls so
they ate cyanide-laced peanut butter and
we can beam themselves up to the [ __ ]
mothership and left the planet well for
all we know they might have really
thought there was a night you know they
believed it Dale [ __ ] they never knew
that that wasn't what happened every day
on the everybody liked him they went to
[ __ ] Bob's Big Boy a lot and [ __ ]
ordered all exactly the same thing and
all the waitresses they all tipped
exactly the same amount they were all
exactly the same and they were just kind
of friendly nerdy Marshall Applewhite
the macho apple boy that's his name
sinister said yeah there's videos of him
talking and he's just yeah and he looks
like he's sucking on like six hits a
acid his eyes are like the size of
[ __ ] sauce yeah he's trying he's he's
very kind of like asexual and cotton you
know he's he's not one sex or another
they were trying to transcend the
limitations of gender and humanity I
guess you could say they were almost
kind of like transhumanists in a way
they were gonna become a me thinking
about them is that I guess I'm not super
bothered by the I mean they're weirdos
but they didn't apparently they didn't
take anyone that didn't want to go and
it wasn't like I mean that guy was like
molesting children and stuff like
earliness that was a long time before
that
but yeah but this cult in particular I'm
not gonna say it's harmless obviously
but at least they only killed themselves
and didn't like take out a bunch of it
yeah it wasn't harmless I mean they all
did you know some of those were some
very susceptible people that yeah it's
like it's a fine line it's like once
somebody is an adult um
it's that peer pressure there in that
yeah it's like it's really bad because
it and it seems like cults in particular
they they know you know Scientology does
and all these [ __ ] cults do it that
you know nexium they're just like
looking for people who are vulnerable
it's across the spectrum though yeah I
mean this happens in this happens in the
mainstream of society I mean you can
look at America right now now in America
all of the Western world right now is is
being polarized into two opposite
directions of two opposite sides and in
a way that the thinking is very tribal
and cult-like it's part of human nature
to do this it's part of human nature to
believe in things and to have a
religious aspect to it and both sides of
this that can come in conflict there's a
religious element even if it's a secular
religion it's moral panic you know moral
panic atonement apocalypse the
destruction of the earth by fire all
that it's all the same themes and you
know goes back to the [ __ ] Mayans and
the Aztecs they were like that it's just
part of human nature and this is gonna
be a transformative [ __ ] episode in
history I also it'll probably also be a
what they call an evolutionary
bottleneck um certain things are gonna
pass the test and certain things aren't
in terms of tricking ideology I it's
okay to have a belief system and an
ideology but it has to be able to
survive reality if it's not real and you
can't make it then it's just that it's
fantasy so we're just gonna have some of
this stuff that you see going on in some
of these cities that have [ __ ] lost
control it's kind of like the equivalent
of the ultimate form of political
protest which is self-immolation like
you see in India where people douse
themselves with gasoline and set
themselves on fire
you basically you're seeing people
setting themselves on fire figuratively
as it gets worse some of them might
actually set themselves on fire that's
how strong belief systems can really
[ __ ] me a strong belief system can [ __ ]
somebody up you're not supposed to be
dream or if you're extreme you should
only be extreme certain in extreme
circumstances which I guess they think
they're in extreme circumstances but
we're gonna see if you ask me it looks
like a Jacobin revolution and [ __ ]
the French Revolution did not end well
yeah just it it backfired it brought an
emperor napoleon because people would
rather have stability than chaos and if
you look at the Jacobin revolution that
was religious it was a moral panic yeah
as we can get back on the domain
somebody Michael Ventris said remember
the cult to try to get on the City
Council and they poisoned a salad bar I
do remember that who the hell was that
um [ __ ] that's so familiar because we
did it was a long time ago I don't even
remember what episode this was but we
did one that had we did a show that had
like four different cults on I'm pretty
sure we talked about children of God but
I don't remember what the other three
were but I do remember reading about
that I just can't remember what they
were called yeah I'm just trying to get
people aware that we're all in a way in
cults the army the army infantry was a
warrior cult political parties are
[ __ ] calls everything is cult-like
corporations are cults you so you really
have to analyze yourself and find out
what it is you believe in are you
believing things you really believe in
or you believe in things that you were
told to believe in you have to be able
to master your own mind you know I mean
are you seeing a world in a certain way
because the information you've been
given was given to you on purpose by
somebody trying to manipulate you cults
do that the cults try to divide and
separate they even try to divide even
try to [ __ ] make you question reality
you know try to make you question the
reality of humans of male and female and
you can get somebody to [ __ ] really
think upside down you know I mean so I
don't I laugh at cults in a certain way
but you got to learn from them because
that's ain't that same [ __ ] could happen
to you well I think like I said that's a
good you know it's that's a good thing
to study be
you can see how because I think anybody
can to an extent can be manipulating
some people obviously are much more
easily manipulate than others and like I
said I think a lot of you know called
some particular religious cults or like
Scientology or something like that which
isn't I don't know if I'd call it a
religious cult but I guess it kind of is
so it's definitely a religion yeah but I
mean the in the sense that I don't know
I'm I guess it's so here's the weird
telling up here's the weird thing about
cults
you would think that stupid people would
be susceptible to call no that's not the
case actually no the smarter you are the
more success susceptible to well because
sometimes people that are really smart
think they can't be fooled and they have
imaginations and they can imagine things
in their minds that don't exist people
that are not very intelligent have to
see things to believe it you know it's a
little they're a little bit in other
words it's think of look at it this way
it's a lot easier to get an intelligent
person to join a cult than it would be
to get say like a shark to join a cult
or a [ __ ] chimpanzee to join a cult
or Pookie or Pookie you can't fool
something that doesn't have much of an
intelligence although Pookie is a lot
smarter than some people yeah
I'm just I'm just saying and even she
would never join us yeah but no I mean
the thing I think from what I've read
I'd have to look again at the studies
but I'm pretty sure like the
intelligence levels are pretty much all
across the board but I do think that
there's a perception that people who are
smart like don't fall for cults but
that's not necessarily the case and like
I said I don't know if it has to do with
intelligence necessarily because a lot
of the people that they target are
people that are emotionally at really
vulnerable places in their life like
they're looking for meaning or you know
they're just coming out of like you know
drug addiction or alcohol addiction or
whatever so they're kind of targeting
people that are like at a low point so
you know and sometimes they're kind of
getting in under their defenses that way
but like I said I do think there's a
thing too with intelligent people that I
think sometimes are not always but I
think they can sometimes be
overconfident and they think that they
can't be fooled so it's easier to
manipulate them in particular ways or in
certain ways but you know I don't know
I'd have to kind of look into that but I
am kind of
the cult of Pookie yeah she needs a she
definitely needs her Oh somebody's
asking about Jim Jones he was the
biggest cult leader when his no he was
not the biggest cult leader well in the
sense that he got like 900 something
people that commit suicide the biggest
cult leader of all time would have been
Joseph Stalin that was a cult
yeah but I'm saying in in the in the
classical sense of the word cult where
you get like the religious cult that
goes down I mean why don't think we
member not sure about Jim Jones happy no
yeah I don't think we did um no there's
probably bigger cults than that in India
yeah but in the West or more in the
Western world like you know that people
know of you know I'm saying what made
what made Jim Jones stand out is the
fact that they all killed themselves
yeah well but they'll all kill
themselves I love most of them but there
are a lot bigger cult leaders that
people don't people have forgotten about
that those the the cults didn't commit
suicide for instance reverend moon was a
korean guy he had a huge cult and they
were kind of controlling but they
weren't very evil um they were just they
just didn't want people talking to non
Muniz yeah and they didn't want people
talking to their family members if they
weren't Muniz Reverend hung some moon
was his name and he was a trip he was
Korean guy he made all kinds of weird
Gnostic claims you know he said that he
had defeated the Soviet Union himself
that was quite a client he said he would
he went into and into trance and went
astral and had astral projection and
went into the spirit world
and [ __ ] undermined the Soviet Union
in the other dimension and then came
back because he couldn't stand communism
he's Korean you didn't like North Korea
either South but that's a wild client
well seeing see saying stuff like that
it's kind of genius because you can't
disprove that yeah but the movies were
kind of interesting they were kind of
like a mixture of
Southern Baptist Christian but with a
whole bunch of say like Edward like
Edgar Cayce type science stuff mixed in
with it probably organized a lot like
Scientology
I don't know if you could pay I don't
know if you had to pay to become a
wizard but that was that Scientology's
claim to fame yeah that's there yeah you
can buy your way into being a [ __ ]
wizard and making people work and not
pay a man oh yeah [ __ ] like that yeah
slave labor basically yeah yeah [ __ ]
yeah the [ __ ] what's-his-name [ __ ]
l rh l ron hubbard he got that idea from
[ __ ] alistair crowley doctor don't
realize that he didn't know crowley but
he knew anton lavey
yeah or did he know crowley no I don't
think I get remember he knew Anton LaVey
I think good to go have to look back
into that LRH was a [ __ ] powerful
cult leader too and that was they own a
lot of stuff you know they own whole
towns they have [ __ ] secret bases out
in the desert yeah oh thank you David
thank you hey hello from the UK hello
from Korea we got like okay well there's
people all over the place all over today
I'm usually talking about Reverend moon
yeah his look into the shin G&G Church
of Jesus in South Korea I know we should
do like a whole other cults extravaganza
we need to do another one of those cuz
there's so many that we forgot I came to
remember what the forward that we
covered on the other one and we probably
need to revisit him because I think we
did that show like back when we were
still like trying to keep him to an hour
which is like so funny to me I don't
even know how did we even [ __ ] do
that my man Zak's asking for a show on
Soviet war crimes it'd be hard to do sit
Soviet war crimes the thing is about a
lot of the things that's crimes against
humanity that the Soviet Union did
wasn't in war there was stuff that they
did to their own population I'm not a
big I'm not a big I'm not I'm not in
real agreement with the concept of war
crime when you really look at history
especially a second world war basically
everyone committed war crimes all sides
were but you had to understand the the
battlefield of the day in the situation
of the day well
basically the United States okay
the American in the Soviet tale of the
destruction of the of the of the Nazi
Empire the Third Reich is that it was a
war of good versus evil actually is more
like a war of evil versus evil
the Nazis weren't destroyed by good they
were destroyed by evil a greater evil
than them in the form of the Soviet army
raping and pillaging its way into
Germany and [ __ ] burning everything
down and on the other side it was the
American Army Air Corps basically
dropping fire on sleeping German
children so you're out there as a German
soldier trying to fight to protect your
country on the Eastern Front but your
wife and children are all [ __ ] burned
up back home so it can just really
sapped the morale of the German people
and it broke the [ __ ] or production
of the Germans now some people would say
that's a war crime well you had to do
what you had to do there were
technological limitations in the Second
World War it you wanted to do target
pinpoint bombing a German war production
facility but to do that you had to fly
down low where you'd get shot at and
shot down by [ __ ] anti-aircraft
artillery so you had to bring the the
bombing runs up to a higher altitude
when you did that you missed them you
missed the target so in order to hit you
had to make a whole bunch of planes drop
a whole lot of bombs and most of them
would miss and fall into the damn
neighborhood some of them would hit the
damn factory so most of your bombs
killed civilians which actually did more
damage than destroying the factory and
later when the factors are destroyed the
Germans just moved war production into
people's houses it did that in [ __ ]
Japan too
so now you have to target the civilians
to stop the war productions because in
reality in a real war every civilian is
war material they're doing something to
further the war machine
making weaponry or they're making future
soldiers by having children so these
were apocalyptic Wars they weren't war
as if where you're trying to get an
agreement out of the enemy you're just
trying to destroy the enemy it's you
only it was the only way so in those
days and even in the day when I was a
soldier which I was being trained for
basically the [ __ ] World War 3 which
is the [ __ ] nuclear apocalypse the
whole idea was to get the [ __ ] over with
and target the civilians you fight your
way to be through the enemy army and
just hit him where they live and that
was ultimately what it was you had to do
it was a primitive type of warfare like
[ __ ] you see 2,000 years ago between the
[ __ ] Germans and the ancient Romans
there were Wars of just annihilation and
the US Army hasn't been like that a long
time that's why they lose that's why
they lose all right they're trying to be
policemen instead of soldiers it doesn't
work and it stopped working around the
time of [ __ ] Operation Restore hope
which they tried to get us to go on that
mission that was Somalia Somalia was
[ __ ] oh man I could do a whole show on
Somalia Somalia happened just like we
said it would happen when you got in
there to kill those warlords to rip the
food all of them would turn against you
because the only thing that mattered was
they saw white people killing black
people so they everybody in the damn
nation turned against him so we had to
leave and so it's just you can't get
involved in [ __ ] like that don't get
involved in other people's civil wars
you can't be the world policeman this is
a [ __ ] fantasy which the America is
learning this right now
you should have learned it in Vietnam
well we got involved with a vietnam
vietnamese civil war against basically
two weak enemies and they kicked our
[ __ ] ass yeah well you know and
people we have all these weapons and
tanks and jets ice shits all worthless
in [ __ ] Afghanistan getting our asses
kicked by 90 IQ dudes in flip-flops just
rifles whipping your ass because you
can't bring to bear on a mini weapons on
him cuz it's not a war you know but so
war that kind of wars obsolete
go back to almost kind of like Roman era
Wars that's the future
that's non-uniformed armies terrorists
that's the future and civil wars yeah
yeah well on a happier note really
apocalypse that Nostradamus tell you
something we are in the [ __ ]
apocalypse it's just beginning
this is not how these things end this is
just how they begin you'll see yeah
we'll see I was gonna I was gonna like
say on a happier note that I was gonna
say is anybody even watching that new
Gordon Ramsay show but yeah yeah yeah it
seems kinda like lame ya know going
Ramsay got a good show what's it called
again uncharged uncharted yeah really
they only did the second one we're only
on the second one I guess it's on what
is it on Sunday nights I think it's on
that geo because we don't like watch TV
we have like the fifty bajillion channel
package because it came chief with the
Internet but um we hardly ever watch it
but um yeah I think it's on the National
Geographic Channel and just started a
couple weeks ago so I guess it's a thing
where he goes to some sort of
out-of-the-way area and he has a week to
like learn all the local cooking
techniques and then there's like a big
thing at the end where he has to feed
everybody
so like the one he did the first week
was Tasmania and then the one we saw the
one that was on Sunday this Sunday and
it was South Africa he was in like part
of South Africa and next week I think
he's doing Louisiana right he's doing
like he's going down the bayou and they
showed like a little bit of that you
know for a throw flip-flop at the right
angle they're asking if we should start
saving first-generation P Mandel say
they water would be better give the
water filtration and [ __ ] don't go in
the desert [ __ ] you want [ __ ]
moving water nearby that's what I mean
it's like every time we want we have
watched that show I shouldn't be alive
now I kind of want to go back and start
watching that show I don't know if it's
still on don't go in the ocean and don't
go in the desert same [ __ ] yeah
you don't have to tell me like not to go
in those I grew up like right now I grew
up in Daytona Beach which is like right
on the ocean and it's like I I would not
go more than like a few [ __ ] feet out
there cuz man they're sharks jellyfish
and I'm not going out in a boat in the
middle of [ __ ] ocean and then end up
in this [ __ ] rap salute I remember
that guy and he was in that [ __ ] raft
and he was a how long was he in that
[ __ ] raft I mean at least the raft
had like a roof on it oh that one dude
no he was out in it
Oh who's long - it was a law was not
have like four or five months yeah it
was like some ridicul don't know I don't
know yeah he was and he was just sucking
survived with his head hanging out
looking into the water and he was
catching stuff yeah he was like taking
fish and I think he was squeezing water
out of the fish too because there was
any because that was freshwater catching
water too because it had that yeah
that's true so he was catching water and
do I mean he lost like 50 [ __ ] pounds
or so I think that there's like four of
my yeah it was like a ridiculously long
time I couldn't like my ground
inflatable survival raft yeah I mean
like I said it was good that it had it
was one of the ones that had like a
little triangular thing on top so that
probably saved because if he didn't have
that you probably would have died of
exposure he must have gone insane man
for four months four months of and he
would see ships go by they didn't see
him well yeah this is like [ __ ] 90 I
mean the ocean yeah no thank you
like the ocean has always scared the
[ __ ] [ __ ] out of me I'm not like [ __ ]
um you know and like I said I'm not
going across the desert either so yeah
I'll probably be safe so you make any
questions or anything you guys should do
a show on the North Sentinel island I'm
still laughing at like saving her fins
fins and eyes for vitamins yeah I
thought I thought he was he was like
taking fish and I think he was like
squeezing water out of them too like cuz
that's kind of like fresh water said
North Koreans believe holding hands too
long can get you pregnant yeah another
one that another one is good one all
right oh thank you jack what's a chinese
couple this this happened china has no
real pornography and no sex education
this is this is maybe about six seven
eight years ago now i don't think they
realized that there might be a problem
they might have to give people sex
education couple got married a young
couple and they couldn't get pregnant
[ __ ] they kept testing the girl on
the guy they couldn't figure out why
they couldn't get pregnant turned out he
was going anal on her yeah he thoughts
that he thought that was how it was done
can't grow baby in your butt no well
this is just kind of like and this was
um I don't this wasn't a Chinese person
but I'm pretty sure this was an American
person I'm not sure if this is true or
not but I had heard that there is at
least one one man that has gone online
saying that like because I think there
was kind of a thing where you know
people have been arguing against like
having a particular attacks like on
tampons and you know sanitary napkins
like you know maxi pads and stuff and
are saying that that's not cool and
everything and he was saying you know
why do you even need those because why
can't you just hold it just hold it just
hold it until you get home yeah and more
than one person okay now see this is
what this I don't know I mean well I
don't know I'm not so sure about that
because there are some stupid people out
there so people actually thought that a
woman could hold your period block
you're holding like you're holding pee
yeah that's not how that works I wish it
works like that but it doesn't year old
uh well see that was in there yeah I
think it was a like an older teenager
dude I got 19 or 20 year olds I've
gotten into fights with people that
assessment stupid [ __ ] online to turn
out a [ __ ] fight we're like a ten
year old I I just assume everybody that
says something stupid I just
he says advice on ways to deal with
existential dread how do you define
existence I don't know man that's well
that's just like a general dread about
kind of everything going to [ __ ] I mean
I the only way I deal with it it's
probably the only way anyone could deal
with it cuz like I said it's it's kind
of too big for anybody one person to do
anything about so I kind of I don't want
to say that it's like oh you go thank
you no way thank you very much um you
know I don't want to say like you know
just absolve any responsibility for
doing anything
you talked but I'm just saying
that you disagree on what we know you
just have to like find you know find joy
find hope where you can find it it's
like you know what I mean you can't just
like your lie it's okay to check out of
that kind of stuff I have to get [ __ ]
Buddhist about this [ __ ] yeah and then
yeah which isn't another form of [ __ ]
Nietzsche and you have to understand the
[ __ ] teachings of Nietzsche and
Siddhartha all right you're not here to
have a good time life isn't about
happiness all right it's just is it you
know life is mostly about suffering okay
and you suffer because you desire things
that either disappoint you in the end or
your desire and things that you'll never
have or you'll desire things that you
get then you get sick of so your life is
just a constant walk and [ __ ] and then
getting sick of it and then want
something else and getting sick of that
all right until you give up this [ __ ]
concept of [ __ ] being dependent on
things and wanting things that need
things soon as you become that you
become him you'll reach an enlightened
didn't difference it's where it won't
really [ __ ] matter all right yeah now
let's agree on reality it has been
demonstrated that if you live in certain
areas you can't you can't depend on
police to protect you or your property
that's a [ __ ] heavy break from the
social contract especially when you're
dealing with society that says that you
can't defend yourselves and you can't
have guns and we can't defend you now
that's a huge [ __ ] problem take care
of yourself all right
[ __ ] them they can't even they can't
help themselves okay just you so there's
no you can't expect them to be there
when you need them which goes back to
your first and second Amendment rights
in the United States you can speak your
mind unless the [ __ ] mob of people
comes to your house and [ __ ] kills
you over it all right which is like
something out of them with Salem witch
trials speak your mind and defend
yourself get you get the the ability and
the knowledge and the means to defend
yourself
it won't be that as bad as you think
actually it's just going
back to the way it was in the 1800s
there weren't a lot of cops people had
to watch out for themselves and it's
you're gonna start seeing a return to a
lot of traditional ways of life
especially if the economy collapses in
the way that the Soviet Union collapsed
millions of people died through lack of
medicine starvation fighting fighting
between breakaway republics that will
probably happen here if this goes hot
which I don't see any I don't see how
this isn't gonna go hot it's just it's
not just me saying this I'm gonna refer
you to a guy named Terence pops pio PPS
he's on YouTube
he's a 30 year plus Special Forces
veteran and Ranger veteran he's funny as
[ __ ] and he will give you an entire
intelligence briefings the way he kind
of get in the military he has a jokes
through the whole thing to get you
oriented to oriented about what's
actually happening and what kind of war
this is it is a war it just hasn't been
called that yet but the history books
will say that it has already started and
I think it started several years back
red harvest says embrace the suck
embrace the suck learn to master the
suck learn to make the suck fuel you and
Mickey although like I said you know and
in some ways too you feel don't feel
like you have to be responsible for
everything that's going on or friends
you know your friends and you know what
I mean and it's like and it's okay to
like check out for a little while and
just like go have a good time and watch
a stupid movie or something like that
it's like don't feel like you have to
stay plugged in all the time because
that's just not good for anybody's
mental health and we can't have
everybody like [ __ ] flipping out and
go oh but oh and I was I laughed because
I didn't want it to go away but you kept
talking but Christine said what I was
saying about like holding the Pirie
blood yeah she says you're laughing but
I heard that crap isn't nurse I had to
keep a straight face talking with the
face I told you there's nothing that you
can say that it's so stupid that
somebody somewhere does not believe it
and it does not surprise me in the least
that some some teenage boy somewhere or
maybe an older kid older man I don't
know would not know that you can't just
hold in your period yeah that does not
shock
yeah and that you could make a baby in
your butt yeah why was he only putting
it in her butt did he say guess you
thought it went in one area went in one
hole came up I guess maybe he was like
watching a magician because like if you
do like put like a you know a thread or
something like up your nose you can
bring it out your you know your mouth so
maybe he thought it was that kind of
maybe he got some idea maybe he
consulted Chinese medicine and
misunderstood what the Chinese medicine
said so I'm like is the Chinese medicine
says some old consecrated [ __ ] that's
it's just that's very funny to me and
like I said every woman on earth was
like yeah we wish when's the cookbook
coming out it's a man we got another
[ __ ] you have to do first well yeah but
I mean I I wanted to start like working
on it soon I mean like what we have like
all babies like laid out and how we're
gonna put him and I have sort of like a
rudimentary layout although like I said
I want to like you know finesse it like
once we figure out like how long all the
recipes are gonna be and stuff like that
but it's it's gonna be a six months job
I mean I think it'll be by the end of
the year I would think because I'm still
working on my faceless villain for a
book as well right but I probably want
to get the cookbook out before that like
you know I'm trying to like just work on
one project at a time but it's kind of
hard I keep like going back and forth
between because you know work on the
show as well but you know it'll it'll be
probably before Christmas I would
imagine yeah cuz she said gonna need all
this spam recipes for the apocalypse
yeah no this okay these dudes you see in
the what they called the chop and he
sees people pulling down statues and all
this crazy [ __ ] that they're doing they
have no idea what they're asking for all
right they have no idea they're not only
are they not ready for this
cops aren't ready for this all right
they had a ex-military ex combat veteran
cop he made a video as he was telling
the other cop stages you guys aren't
rough like I'm ready for this he got
fired but he was gonna quit anyway and a
lot of cops are quitting it's very easy
to - well trained men can [ __ ] defeat
an entire police force in about a week
and get him to walk off [ __ ]
jobs but by using the same tactics that
were used in your Indian Baghdad
you just keep calling the police into a
bad situation where you're waiting for
them then you get on their [ __ ]
frequencies and [ __ ] say we're gonna
do it again we're gonna keep calling you
and they'll stop answering the [ __ ]
calls they'll walk off because cops are
not soldiers
they're there for a paycheck all right
they'll collect their family and run all
right and then when she just starts
breaking down don't depend on the US
military to be there for you they're
gonna run they're gonna go back home
just like the [ __ ] Soviet soldiers
did they're gonna go back home with
their equipment and they're gonna fight
for their local neighborhood don't mean
don't mean to disappoint you but that's
just that's not how that works the the
Federal Army was made for a different
situation it wasn't made it was made for
warring States or conducting Wars
outside you know outside the United
States it can't conduct a war inside the
United States and not remain coherent it
would [ __ ] break apart into a bunch
of factions you'll see let's hope that
they can stop it but I don't think they
can I think I think that I think the
Titanic has already hit the iceberg
they're just rearranging the damn deck
chairs and the bands playing that's
what's really going on yeah I mean you
know and I got active duty guys that I
talked to I know what's going on know
what they're telling them and ain't good
they're getting a lot of confusing mixed
messages this means that the General
Staff officers don't know what to do
okay because they're from different
parties you forgot about that
but it's Republicans and Democrats are
in the general officer corps all right
you're not gonna get any coherent
response out of that organization all
right just today or might have been
yesterday a group of armed militiamen
went to a protest to try to in New
Mexico try to prevent some people from
toppling over a statue of some ass of
some of some conquistadors the
protesters drove the dudes off and they
ran armed men down and
forced one-armed man to [ __ ] shoot
the guy to protect himself then the cops
came and the cops arrested the [ __ ]
militia guys well where were the cops
where aren't the cops defending the damn
statue there's no law and order anymore
and the cops are gonna choose whatever
side is going to give them the least
trouble and at first they're gonna say
we'd rather arrest these militiamen then
we're let then arrest these protesters
but we might lose our job but the
militias are going to retaliate by
attacking the cops and calling the cops
traitors and then when the cops start to
lose the loot
cops are kind of soldier like they're
gonna choose the strong horse they're
gonna go yeah [ __ ] the police i'ma join
the militia and then the militia will
swell and then they'll eventually become
regional and state armies because the
organized armies will be paralyzed
because they're bureaucracies they're
fat they're bloated in their [ __ ]
corrupt with cancer they have
conflicting political ideas and in a
world of gray black and white wins in
other words purity wins not confusion so
when chaos starts to ensue it's the
people that believe and the most
intolerant will win the side that kills
the most people and can manage terror
the best wins and that's just the way
history is it's not about got right or
wrong and it's not about good or evil
it's just about who becomes Genghis Khan
first the bees nest movie says don't
blame a clown for being a clown keep
asking yourself why you keep going to
the circus that's right you play stupid
games you win stupid prizes and I'm just
telling you that's a prediction from
Nostradamus you're not gonna hear that
anywhere else not from the official
sources because that's not what they
want to tell you you can only make
predictions of the future when you can
face something you don't want to [ __ ] it
here all right that all you gonna say
that's all I'm gonna say about this [ __ ]
all right this is not what I want to say
this is not what I want to hear it's
just what I'm seeing the United States
is not a special place
it's it's a country like any other
country except it's a lot more heavily
armed and it has a lot of patriotic
people and a lot of people that don't
like the United States all in the same
spot
the best possible outcome would be some
kind of peaceful separation but I don't
see that happen not at first
yeah all right well we've been going on
for more than an hour yeah I mean bring
you buddy down yeah and I was like now
I'm really bummed out thank you I was
just hoping to do like a fun little show
because we didn't have a 200th episode
well we didn't have a two-ounce upset
but we already put it up so put it up
early all right so I guess we will wrap
up this stream for today we might do
another one tomorrow it'll probably be a
movie review and then Thursday I'll
probably put up my witching hour show
so I'll we'll figure out what time we're
gonna do it tomorrow what movie it's
gonna be and stuff like that and I'll
let everybody know probably around the
same time 2 o'clock because that seems
like a good time for us to do it so
thanks everybody that dropped by and
thanks for everybody that donated yeah
and uh we'll see you guys again and
cover your own ass well I think
everybody does cover your own ass we'll
see you tomorrow you don't bring me down